[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 journal ou
sommes le lundi et 5 décembre voici les
titres de l'actualité locale
plus de 80 millions d'euros de dons de
promesses de dons la 30e édition du
téléthon se dérouler ce week-end sur
l'ensemble du territoire à voisins le
bretonneux l'événement a montré une
nouvelle fois un bel élan de générosité
présenter des années de travail en
seulement douze minutes c'est le
principe de télex saclay la deuxième
édition de cet événement était organisé
en partenariat cette année avec l'estac
à l'école d'ingénieurs basée à saint
quentin en yvelines
enfin comment se préparer en cas de
crise dans les transports en commun un
exercice test incendie a réuni
l'ensemble des acteurs de la sécurité à
la gare routière de saint quentin en
yvelines nous y étions
mais on ouvre ce journal sur les
transports en commun franciliens qui
seront tous gratuits demain sur
l'ensemble du réseau une conséquence de
l'épisode de pollution de l'air qui se
poursuit sur l'ensemble de
l'ile-de-france à noter également que la
préfecture de police de paris a mis en
place pour demain mardi 6 décembre la
circulation alternée à paris et dans 22
villes de la proche banlieue pourront
donc circuler uniquement les véhicules
dont le numéro sur la plaque
d'immatriculation et père
les années passent la mobilisation
perdure on pourrait résumer ainsi la 30e
édition du téléthon qui se tenait ce
week-end sur l'ensemble du territoire
avec 80 millions d'euros de promesses de
dons et comme chaque année les communes
de saint quentin en yvelines ne se sont
associés à l'événement
c'était le cas par exemple à
voisins-le-bretonneux où de nombreuses
nombreuses actions étaient organisées un
reportage d'anne laure languit et
nicolas d'andry ici à voisins le
bretonneux pas de plateaux de télévision
la 30e édition du téléthon s'est
déroulée dans le gymnase des pyramides
l'endroit a été transformé pour
l'occasion achat de livres buvette
entraînement sportif et spectacles il y
avait mille façons de donner pour la
recherche de traitements contre les
maladies rares
quel que soit son âge sa taille sans
religion sont truffés on s'en fiche quoi
l'important c'est de penser aux enfants
qui sont malades aux familles qui bat
qui se prennent-ils gicl les élus de la
commune se sont eux aussi mis à
contribution leurs pédalage alimenter
une partie du gymnase en électricité
pour tous ces jeunes qui ne peuvent pas
avec leur handicap faire du sport et
bien nous on essaye de mettre justement
les muscles à l'honneur pour eux et
surtout pour que les gens fassent un don
donc on va pédaler jusqu'à 19h ce soir
on a commencé à 10 heures ce matin pour
participer aux activités sportives pas
de somme minimale chacun donnait ce
qu'ils voulaient un principe auquel a
adhéré jérôme et sa famille venue exprès
pour l'événement c'est un moment des dés
de convivialité et aussi de
sympathique et joyeux là c'est
aujourd'hui c'était du sport
tout le monde peut être touché par des
maladies neurodégénératives
tout le monde peut être victime d'un
grave accident dont personne n'est à
l'abri de besoin d'une recherche
médicale optimisée et le fait d'associer
là population à ces grands projets de
recherche je crois que c'est un élément
fondamental à la fin du week-end ces
animations ont permis de collecter plus
de 7000 euros au plan national ce sont
80 millions trois cent mille euros de
promesses de dons qui ont été atteints
et n'oubliez pas à ce propos qu'il est
encore possible de faire un don pour le
téléthon vous avez jusqu'à la fin de la
semaine pour ceux ci appeler le 36 37 ou
alors rendez vous sur le site internet
afm tirer telethon.fr dans un tout autre
domaine l'université paris saclay
organisé il ya quelques jours sa
deuxième édition d'été d'aix saclay
l'objectif présenté une thèse de
plusieurs années en seulement douze
minutes l'événement était organisé
mercredi dernier à l'edf lab de
palaiseau et retransmis en simultané
dans dix lieux différents dont notamment
l estaca à saint quentin en yvelines un
reportage de michael et demi d'euros et
patrick jacques de dixmude à une scène
un public et 12 minutes pour présenter
une thèse de plusieurs années le
phénomène universel télex investi ce
mercredi 30 novembre l'edf club de
palaiseau cet événement était organisé
pour la deuxième année consécutive par
paris saclay en partenariat avec saint
quentin en yvelines
cette année douze intervenants
participer à ce rendez-vous dans les
profils il ya un peu de tout en fait à
temps il ya le premier c'est un
scientifique qui est aussi philosophe il
ya thierry marx qui est un chef étoilé
mais c'est vrai un quelqu'un qui s'est
fait par lui même c'est un parcours
personnel
donc en fait il ya des chercheurs
entrepreneurs artistes et des
aventuriers comme avec ghislain bardot
pour un cadeau pour lui le thème retenu
au delà des limites
une problématique qui a attiré plus de
600 spectateurs dans la salle
au delà des limites c'est un sujet
effectivement qui a fait assez large et
très intéressant il est la diversité
dans les intervenants et
il est d'assez bonne qualité parce que
j'allais mieux de regarder l'événement
est également retransmis en direct dans
dix sites de la région parisienne dans
les yvelines une retransmission était
programmée à l'école d'ingénieurs estaca
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines pouvoir y
aller comme ça en plus près juste après
les cours c'est très pratique et comme
je pars tu es en moins conférence tedx
je suis content de pouvoir revenir à
l'estaca aujourd'hui le tedx saclay
reviendra pour une troisième édition
l'année prochaine l'événement sera cette
fois-ci organisée à l'école d'ingénieurs
centrale supélec dans les hauts-de-seine
le thème a déjà été dévoilé les
intervenants devront plancher sur le
service du vivant objectif se préparer
en cas de danger un exercice de sécurité
incendie à la gare routière de saint
quentin en yvelines était organisée
vendredi 2 décembre dernier une
opération planifiée par la préfecture
des yvelines en collaboration avec la
ville de montigny le bretonneux et
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines à la permis vous allez le voir
aux acteurs de la sécurité de
s'entraîner en cas de situations réelles
et dangereuse un reportage de nicolas
landry
[Musique]
un incendie s'est déclaré dans le tunnel
de la gare routière de saint quentin en
yvelines
les derniers passagers sont évacués
problème un bus est passé malgré l'
alerte dans le cadre d'un exercice réel
ça pourrait être un gros problème
puisque la station souterraine étant
évacués on peut avoir des phénomènes de
fumée et de flammes qui met en péril les
voyageurs
là pour le coup c'est une petite
défaillance qu'on doit corriger tous les
accès sont bouclés par les agents de
sécurité
les pompiers interviennent sur l'
incendie et tentent d'évacuer une
personne de la zone dangereuse ski bus
agents de sécurité et pompiers sont
mobilisés sur cet exercice planifié par
la préfecture
objectif tester la validité des
consignes et les interactions entre les
différents acteurs lors de l'opération
sous l'oeil attentif des agents de
montigny le bretonneux et de saint
quentin en yvelines
je rappelle que les garçons sous
l'autorité des préfets
donc on a un sérieux qui songe à ray 2d
plan de sécurité incendie sur ce domaine
nous on y participe
appel des secours évacuation des
passagers coordination des équipes la
gestion de l'opération est réalisée au
pc de sécurité
je suis satisfait ça s'est bien passé
les informations ont été transmises les
agents ont fait un travail qu'il fallait
pour moi pas de problème corps un nouvel
exercice devrait être prévue au début de
l'année 2010 est dans le reste de
l'actualité l'agroécologie fait son
chemin à la bergerie nationale après
avoir été certifié biologique en mai
dernier le lait de la ferme de
rambouillet sera maintenant transformer
pour être distribués sous la forme de
fromage lait pasteurisé ou encore yaourt
une belle initiative qui profitera au
restaurant d'entreprise d'ile-de-france
et aux lycées de la région nous étions
la semaine dernière sur place pour
l'inauguration de ce nouvel atelier de
transformation
reportage de patrick jacques de dixmude
et camille lambert un fromage ou un
yaourt bio logique tout droit venus
d'île de france c'est l'objectif que
s'est donné la bergerie nationale à
rambouillet cela fait déjà huit mois que
le lait certifiés biologiques
la structure a inauguré jeudi 1er
décembre son nouvel atelier de
transformation
la production de lait est ancienne ce
qui a changé ces dernières années c'est
la conduite du troupeau puisque nous
respectons maintenant les principes de
l'agro écologie et nous sommes
labellisés agriculture biologique donc
dans ce cadre là on a réfléchi aussi à
la commercialisation de nos produits
puisque
c'est bien de produire un lait de
qualité biologique mais il faut aussi
avoir des circuits qui permettent de
commercialiser à proximité est
transformé à proximité entre l'ue et ces
circuits sont représentés par deux
partenaires la ferme de 6 j ai la
société hôte nta dans leur nouveau local
il développe sur place toute une gamme
de produits laitiers
destiné aux particuliers mais aussi aux
cantines scolaires
la production de rambouillet alimentera
les ai vu nenê val d'oise ou dans les
collectivités locales c'est à dire les
collèges les lycées les écoles primaires
ça va représenter à terme un quart de
notre chiffre d'affaires donc de notre
nouveau le chiffre d'affaires et ça va
représenter à peu près une production de
30 mille yaourt supplémentaires par
semaine avaient pas simplement
producteur d'une matière première on est
on est vraiment là pour faire de
l'alimentation et donc on a on a un vrai
échange entre les transformateurs et
nous les producteurs pour sans cesse
adapter nos pratiques et notre système
de production en fonction des rendu
qu'on a sur la partie transformation
avec le passage au biologique la
bergerie nationale a pu valoriser sa
production vendue auparavant 250 euros
les mille litres
elle atteint maintenant 570 euros une
manière de se développer dans une
filière en danger en 15 ans la moitié
des exploitations agricoles a disparu en
sport une convention tripartite vient
d'être signé entre la direction des
services départementaux de l'éducation
nationale des yvelines et le district
départemental de football notamment pour
favoriser et améliorer la découverte du
foot dans le cadre de l'enseignement
sportif à l'école écoutez les précisions
de serge clément le directeur académique
au micro de nicolas d'andré l'objectif
ce n'est pas simplement d'assurer
l'équipement de de certaines de nos
écoles en sachant qu'on a des kits
adapté que fournit la fin de la
fédération mais aussi et surtout de
bénéficier de la compétence et de la
compétence à la fois en matière
d'apprentissage du football mais aussi
en matière de d'éducation de nos jeunes
enfants il y en a
sinon une dynamique qui a été portée
amplifié par notamment l'euro 2016 qui a
été particulièrement bien porter dans le
département on referme ce journal avec
de la danse et le battle be the one qui
s'est déroulé samedi 3 décembre à la
halle culturel de la mairie à trappes
plusieurs compétitions ont eu lieu toute
la journée le public a pu découvrir
notamment du breakdance du new style ou
encore du krump plusieurs yvelinois
participer à cette journée battle
reportage d'haussmann vendeurs d et
nicolas landry et figure sur une main
coupole danse au sol ou encore new style
voilà ce que les spectateurs ont pu
découvrir lors du battle be the one ces
petits 3 décembre à la hâte culturel de
la merise attrape et pour gagner cette
compétition
les règles sont strictes donner du
plaisir au public et être en rythme par
notre traiteur du ressenti sur le son
donc ça dépend des sentiments que à le
danseur sur le sont donc on a des
critères dans le hip hop qui sont le
boom bap c'est à dire de respecter le
boom bap donc ça bien de lutter quoi
c'est un battement du coeur qui permet
justement 2 et danser
donnez un ressenti au public pour
jusqu'à jusqu'au moment où l'usure c'est
c'est l'instinct sur le moment et parmi
les danseurs il y avait des yvelinois
comme choupi et bambino de danseurs de
new style originaire de trappes
malgré de très bons passages de leur
part ils ont perdu dès le premier tour
donc au niveau du battle ressentira très
bon ressenti ça c'est grave bien passé
grosse expérience dans ces contrées
haïtienne insee sachant que c'est pas
n'importe qui c'est à dire que quand on
savait qu'on allait tomber contre le
prometteur on savait qu'il fallait
envoyer directement parce que ça allait
être chaud entre les deux premiers
niveaux il était super héros vit
vraiment vraiment où il est tombé contre
eux diane niveau dans le motel il était
haut mais s'étaient tous les deux que
lors de cette deuxième édition il y
avait plus de 500 spectateurs et plus de
100 danseurs venus de toute la france
pour s'affronter au point où on en est
franchement ce matin ça commençait à
vraiment être
un gros battle honey nouveau on est
nouveau dans ce milieu là dans la
création de ce battle là c'est notre
deuxième événement mais ça prend de
l'ampleur et aux pme seront en effet de
ramener des grosses têtes ou flâneuse
heures mais ça va prendre
et pour cette deuxième édition les
vainqueurs sont salim pour le breakdance
sarcelles et dit andy pop et jamie pour
lokeren
c'est la fin de ce set 8 journal rendez
vous demain pour une nouvelle édition en
attendant les programmes se poursuivre
sur notre antenne bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]